die anwendung von künstlicher
intelligenz ki kann fatale folgen haben
ein us forschungsteam hat jetzt ein fall
aufgelegt bei dem der algorithmus alles
andere als treffsicher und
unvoreingenommen ist stattdessen
diskriminiert er schwarze patientinnen
und patienten und das mit dramatischen
folgen
und das ist nicht die einzige ki diese
schmach von versagt krieg zum science
und fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpassen sie nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen und vielen dank für den
spannenden dem vorschlag von ernst über
die telegramm community dort bekommt ihr
die videos vor allen anderen und zwar
werbefrei und können mitdiskutieren der
link ist hier und ami und in der video
beschreibung konkret geht es um einen
algorithmus den krankenkassen in den usa
millionenfach eingesetzt haben es
handelt sich hier also nicht um einen
einzelfall
die software ist dafür zuständig über
den weiteren behandlung bedarf der
patientinnen und patienten zu
entscheiden
im einzelnen geht es darum diejenigen
kranken auszuwählen die eine intensivere
medizinische betreuung bekommen sollten
das ziel der krankenkassen hierbei der
gesundheitszustand dieser patientinnen
und patienten soll sich auf keinen fall
weiter verschlimmern und horrende kosten
sollen so verhindert werden
der algorithmus erstellt also aus den
krankenakten und den kosten die bereits
durch die patientinnen und dem patienten
verursacht wurden eine bewertung des
risikos daraus kann dann abgelesen
werden inwieweit eine besondere
medizinische betreuung angeraten ist
dazu sie hat obermeier von der
university of california
sie verlassen sich auf diesen
algorithmus und patienten für hochrisiko
management programme auszuwählen alle
kranken die dann zu den oberen drei
prozent gehören bekommen sofort intensiv
programme von den kassen bewilligt
diejenigen für die der algorithmus
mindestens einen wert von 55 prozent
ausgespuckt hat werden zu einem gespräch
mit ihrem hausarzt eingeladen dieser
kann dann nach rücksprache mit den
krankenkassen weitere medizinische
betreuung veranlassen das us
forschungsteam hat den algorithmus jetzt
genauer ins visier genommen und
untersucht wie die software zu ihren
ergebnissen kommt dafür haben die
fachleute viel arbeit auf sich genommen
und rund 50.000 krankenakten händisch
untersucht ihre ergebnisse haben sie
dann mit den ergebnissen des algorithmus
verglichen wie treffsicher ist er
wirklich bewertet er
patientinnen und patienten mit
unterschiedlichen hautfarben gleich die
antwort ist eindeutig und zugleich auch
erschreckend denn der algorithmus ist
alles andere als unvoreingenommen die
software diskriminiert schwarze
patientinnen und patienten und stuft sie
deutlich seltener als die hellhäutigen
patientinnen und patienten in höhere
risikoklasse nein
im klartext bedeutet das bei einem
vergleichbaren gesundheitszustand
bekommen hellhäutige menschen deutlich
öfter die bewilligung für eine intensive
medizinische betreuung als die schwarzen
patientinnen und patienten letztere
müssen also einen deutlich schlechteren
gesundheitszustand vorweisen um weitere
hilfen bewilligt zu bekommen
das autorenteam fasst es in seiner
studie folgendermaßen zusammen
die schwarzen patienten auf der gleichen
stufe der risiko rangliste hatten
dadurch eine wichtige akteure
krankheitslast als die weißen
damit zeigt ein algorithmus der die
gesundheitsversorgung von millionen
amerikanern beeinflusst eine micky
bekannte rassen bezogene vor eigenen
nochmal ein schlag ins gesicht für diese
art der methodik doch mit diesem
ergebnis gab sich das us forschungsteam
nicht zufrieden und suchte intensiv nach
den ursachen für diese diskriminierung
und sie wurden fündig in der
berechnungsgrundlage der software blieb
ein wichtiger faktor unberücksichtigt
denn bei den berechnungen wurden die
tatsachen außer acht gelassen dass das
us gesundheitssystem an sich bereits
eine strukturelle ungleichheit zwischen
weißen und schwarzen in sich trägt mehr
als 1000 us dollar pro jahr und
patienten und patientinnen werden für
schwarze weniger ausgegeben als verweise
und das bei vergleichbarer krankheits
schwere ein beispiel dafür
in den usa ist das risiko für schwarze
höher bei krankheit und viel zeit
weniger gehalt zu bekommen oder sogar
ihren job zu verlieren eine erkenntnis
mit weitreichenden folgen denn genau
dieser faktor spielt auch bei
algorithmen die in anderen branchen
eingesetzt werden eine entsprechende
entscheidende rolle
die expertin experten gehen deswegen
davon aus dass auch diese systematisch
aber unbeabsichtigt diskriminieren die
fachleute optimierten den entsprechenden
krankenkassen algorithmus und konnten so
die unerwünschte verzerrung beseitigen
statt 18 bekamen plötzlich sie
und 40 der schwarzen patientinnen und
patienten eine bewilligung für intensive
medizinische betreuung das fazit von
saint hill bei nathan der an der studie
beteiligt war
also rhythmen an sich sind weder gut
noch böse aber man muss aufpassen die
man sie konstruiert mich erinnert die
ganze sache an das ergebnis einer
investigativen recherche in der
journalistenvereinigung pro publica
dabei sollte eine software einschätzen
wie hoch das risiko einzelner
strafgefangener ist wieder rückfällig zu
werden
das problem die künstliche intelligenz
nahm die hautfarbe der menschen als
entscheidendes merkmal dafür an
krimineller energie auszuüben das hatte
der algorithmus so aus dem
trainingsdaten abgeleitet und auch das
hatte damals fatale folgen also traue
keiner künstliche intelligenz selbst
wenn du sie selbst programmiert hast und
das übrigens gar nicht so schwer kann
programmieren in zehn minuten von
brainlab also unbedingt anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren cooler kanal
und ansonsten bis dann bleib dran